Image features revisited
In a much earlier lecture, we talked about
the data mismatch problem. That's the fact
that a sensor like a camera emits a large
number of pixels, perhaps 1 million pixels
in every image and it's going to be anything
from 10 to 50 images per second that is an
enormous amount of data.
A machine like a robot requires relatively
little information in order to tell it where
to go an arm type manipulator like shown here
requires simply 6 numbers which described
the angles of the joints of the robot.
A mobile robot like the vacuum cleaner shows
here really only requires 2 numbers to control
its motion, that's its forward velocity V
and its rotational velocity omega.
So, we have the problem with a huge amount
of data coming from a camera sensor, relatively
little data required by the robot. The way
we get around that then is to extract what
we call features from the image and we've
talked a bit in previous lectures about region
features. We've talked about how we can take
an import image. We can find regions which
are sets of pixels with either similar intensity
or with similar color and we can then describe
those regions in terms of their centroid,
their bounding box, moment’s perimeter,
circularity and so on.
We've talked a lot about regions but there
are number of other types of features that
are really useful and interesting and that
I'd like to talk a little bit about.
Most real world scenes contain a lot of lines.
This particular picture of a church, I've
highlighted a number of lines. Some of these
lines come from the contrast between the roof
and the sky, between the roof and the wall,
the edges of windows, the edges of doors and
so on. Certainly, in any man-made environment,
there are enormous number of lines but even
in many natural environments there are lines
as well, perhaps the vertical edges of tree
trunks and so on.
So, lines are very prevalent in the environment
and lines are very simple and compact to describe.
A line might contain a large number of pixels
but is really described by just 2 parameters,
its intercept and its slope.
Now, an interesting question then is: How
do we extract lines in an image, the important,
the dominant lines within an image?
Another class of features what we call point
features and what's overlaid on this picture
of a building here are points in the image
that are interesting, that is they describe
points that are quite distinctive and if I
took another picture of this building, I'd
have a pretty good chance of finding those same points in a different view of the same building.
So, if I'd move my camera, if the sun's come
out, the sun's going behind the cloud, I would
still be able to locate these points. The
overlaid graphical information entails a lot
about these feature points. The center of
the circle indicates the center of this distinctive
pattern that is a pattern that we are very
likely to be able to find in another view
of the same scene.
The size of the circle indicates something
about the scale of the pattern. Is it a very
small distinct pattern or a large distinct
pattern? The radio lines say something about
the orientation of that pattern.